younes vit aujourd'hui on se trouve sur
un manque d'un style hippie un petit
dessin qui est sorti il ya seulement un
mois oui j'ai un peu de retard ça va
c'est les vacances ok oui c'est discute
nul c'est parti on a fait un petit
aspect là dessus je sais pas si vous
vous souvenez
et qu'est-ce qu'il faudra neige [ __ ]
c'est quoi ce délire babe le tgb crise
passe ou ça c'est peut-être ses amis
imaginaires
il marche comme ça tel un bébé vous êtes
parce que c'est un bébé
les copains bizarre la dépouille de
sacrément bizarre quand même ce bébé aux
montures bonjour compte quand allez-vous
ohwawa - qualité les fricadelles fluctue
vous êtes vivants les gars ça ne veut
quand elle fête foraine les maisons il
ya des mémoires partout et on se les
prend dans la gueule comme ça il ya un
flash ya pas de flash par combien fête
foraine nous revoici dans notre berceau
il se relève délicatement est c'est bon
quand je vous mets la beauté de ce jeu
même dans les musiques et où il
s'entraîne demain et la gym à 7 heures
du matin on part dans salt ouvriers
offre duo d'apôtres nickel il a dit
froid il fait il fait tellement froid
j'ai pas su bien ça j'avoue je me
souviens plus trop du jeu mais ce truc
qui vivent en plus mon ami vient à il
est emprisonné donc je vais libérer
j'arrive nous allons te libérer du gros
méchant sais pas qui c'est mais ses
proches sûrement un grand méchant de sa
grand gentil on ne serait pas là [ __ ]
bassi femmes la fenêtre du coup la
chaleur revient lâche pas compris vous
m'en voulais moi je m'en veux beaucoup
plus tard il habite car dans un
cimetière quoi alors mon action pavace
le bûcheron et qu'il est coupé tous les
arbres mais ça n'a aucun rapport sinon
si vous me posez la question du coût lui
il est enfermé il va pas m'aider à bien
regarder ses revenus ça c'était pas là
juste avant oui ça fait fondre la glace
de rien je caresse regarder je la
caresse elle aime ça oh oui oh que oui
les autres ils sont cachés parce qu'ils
ont peur s'il te plaît de l'est j'ai
réussi à tout traduire mais l'art vous
devrez fêter ça [ __ ] à ok donc faut
remonter bien sûr on est à la lumière en
partant toujours à on pense à la factory
t on veut finalement la radio mais vu
que c'est un petit peu sombre je me
souviens plus il n'y a pas une touche
pour sortir dans remonter dix pour voir
plus clair jachère jachère ch dont
panique dont le panic hockey panique
qu'est ce qui se passe et des monstres
en aide à fuck à je déteste c'est mon
psy sont tellement bizarre et est
malsain voilà comme ça fait de noir et
le fut mais moi je voulais juste dormir
poser dans mon berceau et je me retrouve
à devoir retrouver ses potes ou êtes
vous cacher les gabarits des mois il
s'est dit moi un peu à temps mais la
maison ultime oh c'est ma maman à ces
mamans qui
merde à mon avis il faut changer toutes
les fenêtres oui fonctionnement concerne
toutes les fenêtres a c'est quoi ça
c'est la fenêtre
tu te calmes direct bordel secteur froid
on a tous droit ici au québec on va pas
refermer la fenêtre en pl no more
fenêtres on de dire allez petit pavé
montre tout et biceps et tu pousses se
pousse pousse en anjou chemin jusqu'à la
neige qui bloque la com ça oui c'est bon
attention au couteau petit s'il te plait
je suis quand même responsable de toi
pour moment et ce pour éviter de couper
un bras
on est là ah oui ok il est enfermé à la
corde il faut que je ferme la fenêtre
aussi ne t'en fais pas garçons oui tout
faux mais pourquoi j'ai fermé toutes les
fenêtres mais joe objections bordel
vient s'il te plaît non mais bien au
lieu de monter torrent may hamm le frigo
ça fait du froid non théorie de merde
tout rietberg tout près des bruits
bizarres comme ça lorsqu'il réellement
ce partout au hasard de trois fois j'ai
fermé toutes les fnac bordel touche pas
à ce quatuor je remets d'un chauffage
carrément chauffage électrique
la tige ou bleu fausse affaire la
chaleur dans torride merde et personne
soit de mes théories ok je suis un gros
scientifique le grippe a c'est la
solution tient à les grippes à gries
glace j'ai tête une idée allez petit
bébé petit bébé muscles et tu y vas
voilà c'est ça mais jeté sur mon gars
c'est du terrorisme
why so do aussi je peux le faire
regardez où ça va ou quoi je te prends
je te caresse comme d'habitude à mes
amis les animaux ils sont si mignons
voilà sauvegarde en cours ça se sent pas
bon du tout du tout du tout du tout ma
maman qui pète des câbles un peu
apparemment comme ça au foetus s'est
passé allez on y va on y va on y va
excellent dessin et ensuite je peux
tomber de là a indiqué monsieur becca le
b car mon muscle à quoi je disais fait
des sauts de cinq matchs balle à plus de
tailleur comme s'il vous plaît il ya des
jambes
ah non c'est juste une botte il fait
froid faut que j'aie time to carry
famille politique arrive jusqu'à la
neige tel un tel un bonhomme de neige ça
c'est vraiment du lot de fenêtres schumi
de fenêtres dallas texas a fait un petit
adam non or faut que j'arrête là dedans
utilisent et approuvé l'inventaire hop
je veux mettre la cassette blue screen
ça crache et non c'est bon
dessin animé qui nous fait du bien de
rien ou très mignonne didot et
d'ascension fins l'eau bond est juste
que je crois que mes pectoraux compte à
tête c'est un peu glauque
quand tu l'as roma s'est fait un bruit
de chasse dose quand même bon c'est
quand même sacrément étrange peluches
vivantes s'il vous plaît vous êtes vous
oui maman qu'est ce tu fais elle pète un
câble à ça à mon avis c'est ma chambre
et voilà c'est vrai [ __ ] regarder
annoncé peut-être mon papa où j'essaie
de comprendre mais j'ai un peu de mal je
fasse quoi au boeuf mais la peep
si je le bordel alors à part une pipe ya
quoi un pc voilà geek des plus jeune âge
hier 17 usd les touches mmorpg avec ses
pieds comme ça voilà lui joue druide
niveau 90 il avait aussi un petit
téléphone pour discuter avec ses amis
avaient pas skype à l'époque donc voilà
eh bien écoutez avait annoncé pièce
alors on s'en va en moonwalk puisqu'on a
la classe à d'aucuns sous-sol à un étage
c'est quoi le plus sécurisant je dirais
laitages
allez je sais que c'est du sport à
quatre pattes qui arrivent mieux aura
bien sûr il cela est carrément [ __ ]
mais aller dans l'autre sens à cette
fois au mieux ses biens direction le
sous sol tu leur assurant n'avoir en
avouant bois avec soi [ __ ] folle petit
avion j'ai l'a vu avec moi on pouvait
rien faire il ya du sang mec m'arreter
c'est quoi ce délire à temps c'est quoi
ça ma mère qui va étendre le linge
probablement aux fins ou cabines corbeil
owen poubelles dans la main et du sang
par terre peut être qu elle aussi
étendue les tripes d'un animal mort
c'est quoi ce au maire il est parti ai'a
la fenêtre ouverte aux j'arrive j'arrive
ya et je vais vous aider nous en fait
pas à tant faire technique tiroirs voilà
connu dans le milieu du bébé dans le
milieu du moins trois ans allez on y va
ça c'est quoi c'est la lessive je ne
veux pas faire de lessive pour le mans
s'il vous plaît il au juste fermer cette
fenêtre of the je suis tombé malade
c'est au prix de fenêtres ouvertes la
[ __ ] ça fait du courant d'air frais
dans le coup ce n'est pas grave il est
là [ __ ] c'est klaus est le gage que
faire pour l'aider peut avoir un objet
attirer puis courageous avoir du courage
dont be nervous jardin en anglais allez
pour lui libérer de la cage pour libérer
la brosse de la cage copains les
peluches j'arrive pour vous sauver je
chanterai pas d enghien
eyes a fait un mime mais vraiment bien
fait o o il et robinho au dos mais je
voulais plus à nu rexel n'a même pas eu
droit à la caresse familiale faut que
j'aille à l étage
ah ça c'est un parfait tu te crois plus
mal à quoi monstre je rallume la lumière
suis sûr que c'est bien fait peur [ __ ]
on va aller tâche se serait ouvert c'est
sûr mais par toi fillon buts à 1 en
voulait peut-être me protège l essayer
de me faire comprendre qu'il ne fallait
pas monter que le danger était là haut
mais s'il veut qu'on aime oh oh non
[ __ ] c'est juste les lumières doit
c'était un monstre c'est mon avion tu as
fait ton travail et bientôt je prends
mon envol c'est dommage que les athées
l'avion et tu prends pas ton envol alors
que c'est toi qui sont ces enfants vous
ai compris moi l'accusé - faut évacuer
le stress [ __ ] longueur c'est
tellement horrible
qu'est-ce qui se passe oh mon dieu j'ai
vu quelqu'un en robe de chambre
la tête dans le cul à l'opie c'est mon
dieu qu'est-ce qu'on va découvrir en
poussant cette porte une loi [ __ ]
c'est pixar que derrière tout ça les
gars je le savais il ya un trou
attention c'est un piège [ __ ] dernière
peluche
je suis la belle aventure des fermes là
si tu pouvais le faire non poule e fois
les sommets vite on fait comment la sas
est une trappe
c'est pour moi ok mais je me raccroche
et disparaissent quoi ah je crois que ma
mère est battu ok atteint un plus haut
depuis début juin prend pour la méchante
alors qu'en fait c'est la gentille quoi
je suis vraiment pauvre type
elle ramasse ses livres elle fait ses
affaires pour s'en aller aux mamans
ouest mabon s'il te plait ça c'est super
joli comme scène
maintenant j'arrive la porte s'est
ouvert ouais tu vas mounette est
construit nos copains et on avait
retrouvé bobo blop voilà la playbook le
cas d un peu de chez elle est tombée on
avait pu la sauver elle pleure je
l'entends pleurer à moins que ce soit
moi qui pleure ce bébé non cl bibelots
monde plus que bon je te mangerais ap
elle est là elle est là [ __ ] canard
oui
quoi et alors non mais pourquoi donc tu
es méchant tout part que me veux-tu tu
me prend dans les bras
oui tu fais seulement peur hein donc je
pense que tu es méchante mais tu fait
vraiment peur mais je déconne pas alors
non bbox ça m'a brisé le coeur cette
scène mon gars aiment ramène dans le
noir une belle métaphore et ça se
termine comme ça me ramène dans le noir
[ __ ] mais non mais il ya but mais on
n'abandonne pas la famille et
franchement inutile c'est un jeu j'adore
parce qu'il ya une ambiance incroyable
et l'histoire est vraiment belle avec
cette mère alcoolique que la fille voit
comme un monstre c'est vraiment un jeu
avec une ambiance incroyable très beau
graphiquement un officiel
l'histoire est vraiment folle
franchement j'adore ce responsable je
tenais à faire le dlc je trouve ça vous
a plus ces cas n'hésitez pas aimé la
vidéo comme d'habitude une petite pensée
pour notre teddy cayla l'afrique est
seul dans la neige à l'heure actuelle
probablement sous huit kilos de nage
ouais bah voila c'est l'heure de se
quitter c'est les vacances donc je sais
que ce loisir bon tout va bien pour vous
pour moment on se retrouve très vite
dans une nouvelle vidéo où j'espère que
vous qui fait bien de lui nous a
construit à tout le monde
pis
[Musique]
les comptes
mais bon